Pete Davidson finally addresses his
budding romance with Kate Beckinsale
Pete makes his relationship with Kate
S&L official things have been heating up
between 25 year old Pete and 45 year old
Kate since the two were spotted locking
lips at a New York Rangers game the
viral photo drew a lot of attention
especially since there's a 20-year age
gap between the stars
naturally the comedian did not miss an
opportunity to poke fun on Saturday
Night Live's a Weekend Update segment
about Kate's cougar status apparently
people have a crazy fascination with our
age difference but it doesn't really
bother us but then again I'm new to this
so if you have questions about a
relationship with a big age difference
just ask
Leena DiCaprio Jason Statham Michael
Douglas Richard Gere Jeff Goldblum Scott
Disick Dane Cook Derek Jeter Bruce
Willis Harrison Ford Tommy Lee Alec
Baldwin Sean Penn and whoever the
president of France is Mel Gibson Billy
Joel Mick Jagger's Vesta Sloane Eddie
Murphy Kelsey Grammer Larry King Larry
King Larry King Stewart Donald Trump I
think Pete has a point here this is
nothing new in Hollywood but he did lay
out that laundry lists really nicely and
it was super fun Larry King Larry King
Larry King and I think it also speaks to
the double standard of like the men in
Hollywood do this all the time and then
all of a sudden it's a woman and people
are like anyway Pete's back story p-ting
ariana grande called it quits in October
2018 after five months together and a
short engagement Pete and Kate were
first linked together back in January
after they were reportedly seen getting
cozy at a Golden Globes after-party
after months of PDA holding hands in
public taking trips together and their
heavy make out session that seem to
scare queer eyes Anthony Perot ski for
life there seems to be no question that
Pete is off the market is off the market
since their romance began Kate has
remained undefeated as the clap back
Queen when trolls make shady comments
about the relationship one expressed how
they were disappointed in your dating
choice
Kate reply to that comment or writing
fairly let down by your wonky beard but
thought possibly rude to say Savage she
also posted a throwback photo of her mom
Judy Lowe in her prime
one years wrote dear heavens Kate not
Pete Davidson Kate had the best response
quote no that's my mother easy mistake
to make a really easy mistake okay I
know
really love this couple they're really
witty one and they have a pretty good
sense of humor though Pete got some
laughs and some booze when he took on
our Kelly and Michael Jackson take a
look at this if you support the Catholic
Church isn't that like the same thing as
being in our Kelly fan really see the
difference only like one's music is
significantly better Pete explained why
he thinks fans remain loyal despite
recent allegations the reason
everybody's so upset is because our
Kelly and Michael Jackson made great
music you know if I found out Macklemore
did some weird stuff I'd be happy to
free up the space on my iPhone one
thing's for sure Pete will always turn
controversy into comedy but it is nice
to see him openly talking about his
relationship again I think so and he
always used this SNL as a platform to do
that we saw that with ariana grande I
mean but to your point earlier Ashley I
feel like this is a double standard
talking about the age gap because Kate's
a woman yes it is yes it is but we want
to hear your thoughts and of course we
will keep you updated with all the
latest on Pete and Kate be sure to
subscribe to ET until next time I'm ash
Carlson and I'm Courtney teza Noah bye
for now guys
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]